you've written about mit's connection to
Jeffrey Epstein yes he was well
connected at MIT and at Harvard
um what do you what lessons do you draw
about human nature about universities
about all this from from this Saga let
me say this
I believe that universities
if somebody was to for example donate
to a university and donates on the
requirement that the building be named
after them
if the university is taking the
donations and the person is funding a
building
you know and wants to building an in the
afternoon the building should be named
after him hammer or them Harvard is
facing is now at the Sackler building
because Sackler the sacraments have
become now a persona non grata because
of their role in producing the opioids
that caused a huge
scandalous opioid addiction
there are people who want to have
removed the name the Sackler from the
Sackler Art Museum and however
Larry bakhow the president of Harvard to
his credit
has refused to to do that
um and um if it reminds people that the
money was earned through selling opioids
that's good that's good that people
understand that that's where the sackles
got their money they should be bonded in
the mic in in my um uh undergraduate
alma mater Princeton there's a movement
to remove the name Woodrow Wilson
because Wilson was president of
Princeton before he became governor of
New Jersey before he became president of
states
how he got to be Governor New Jersey was
he was someone sufferable that the
trustees of Princeton got an
denomination to run for governor of New
Jersey they had said we had to get this
guy out of here
um and um
not because it was anti-black and
anti-semitic because the trustees were
as well but because he just was
insufferable he drove the faculty crazy
and they got him out
um and um so Princeton was thinking of
changing the name I wrote a letter to
President is saying you know the the
this is part of the University's history
you don't want to re you want to rewrite
history falsely uh Woodrow Wilson was
the president of this institution he was
one of your predecessors he never
answered me either
um I think these people you know they
they know they have no answer
the reason I didn't get a response from
president ice grouper is the same as the
reason I didn't get a response from the
Headmaster of Milton Academy they
understand that what they're doing is
violative of the fundamental precepts of
academic institutions they're ashamed
they that they feel they have no choice
because they feel that they would be
criticized for racism homophobia blah
blah blah blah criticized by how many
people well they feel that they would be
criticized by students and parents and
donors I disagree with that I actually
think there are more people out there
that agree with me than agree with them
yeah by a large margin by a large margin
in what I call the real world which is
the world outside the campus
but academics are afraid they'd be
criticized they're incredibly thin skin
when I say academics I mean academic
administrators they're very thin skin
politically correct holier than now
um as I said I would fire 90 95 of them
and I would be more of um careful in who
I elected in this institution so I said
Pauline gay is probably going to be a
disaster at Harvard
so it takes guts it takes courage to be
in the administration when the task of
protecting the freedom of speech is
there and also
um which in part requires
you to admit and to uphold the mistakes
you have done in the past correct not to
hide them correct and that do you I mean
Jeffrey Epstein for Harvard and for MIT
is a very recent mistake well there's a
debate whether it's a mistake they took
money from him yes okay
is it a mistake to take money from bad
people
do you have to do a morals test of a
potential donor
I don't think so
um It's Complicated because if there are
no conditions attached to it I think
it's emotionally complicated I don't
think that it is rationally complicated
um it's emotionally complicated it's
particularly complicated if they want
naming rights
yes you know the Jeff Jeffrey Epstein's
biological Laboratory
um that that would be a problem for most
universities
um I don't think that naming rights have
to be given to somebody that you that
you don't think is worthy of having
their name I think the university has
the right to say no we'll we'll take
your money but we will not name the
building if you I think they have a
right to do that there's some degree in
which you whitewash the name though if
you not not with naming rights but
if you take the money it allows the
person
in uh public discourse to say that
they're collaborating they're working
together with Harvard and with MIT I
have a problem with universities making
morals tests of the donors
because not every donor is as bad as
Epstein but some of the donors made
their money in Industry by being
rapacious uh by
paying low wages uh by exploiting people
you can uh make the case that
accepting money from the Department of
Defense from DARPA from the United
States organizations that uh contributed
to Waging War and killing hundreds of
thousands of civilians over the past few
decades correct
um folks like the 10-year Professor Noam
chomski who make the case that that is
far more evil than
um accepting money from Jeffrey Epstein
yes
foreign
still Jeffrey Epstein is a known
pedophile yes
so that's why I say I would I would not
give him naming rights
I think the university has the autonomy
to not give naming rights
but I think that giving morals tested
donors is a is a Pandora's Box
what do you think about the aftermath of
the Jeffrey Epstein Saga it feels like
I'm not familiar with Harvard's response
but mit's response seemed to
um fire a few scapegoats
and it didn't seem like a genuine
response
of to the evils that uh human beings are
capable of sort of like rising to the
surface the description in a fully
transparent way of all the interactions
that happen Jeffrey Epstein and what
that means
um yeah what that means about the the
role of money in universities what that
means about just human beings in power
money money is essential to run a
university one of the reasons it's
essential is because the university is
artificially
requires huge amounts of money and
that's partly because of the
administrative Army that they that they
they uh support
and they wouldn't be less dependent on
the Jeffrey epsteins of the world if
they didn't have
the the so it's sort of all part of the
same Circle
but there's a tension here you're saying
we shouldn't be putting a morals test on
money but actually if you make uh
if you expand the amount of money needed
to run the university this you're going
to make less and less up more and more
unethical decisions and as I said I I am
flexible enough to say that I don't
think I would name a building after
somebody who is truly evil I think
university has the has the right to
limit the naming rights uh for donor
um if I was an absolutist I would not
even say that but I'm not an absolutist
um I I have my limits
and that's one of them the Jeffrey
Epstein biological laboratory it's a
little bit much
it feels like there's should be a
requirement on there should be moral
requirements
on who to accept money from but the
question is that the concern you have is
about who gets to decide
and what's the alternative correct I
think there is no alternative I think
that turning down donation because you
you don't approve of the conduct of the
donor it's a Pandora's Box
but I'm just sickened by the fact that
an evil human being was allowed to walk
in the halls of a university I love
so what do we do with that well he was
telling me that none of the students are
evil are you telling me none of the
faculty members are really you telling
me some none of the administrators are
evil
um but that doesn't
sure sure
so uh saying scapegoating saying that
Jeffrey Epstein is evil can help us
forget
can Aid Us in forgetting that there is
other evil in the world and uh some of
it might be roaming still the halls of
MIT and Harvard Hey listen I won't tell
you the name but I represented somebody
in the MIT Administration a few years
ago uh who is who's charged with the
sexual improprieties against students
um and as a lawyer I represented that
person
um uh people say how could you represent
you know some of the people that
represented bad people
see how can you represent them I said
well if I was a cardiologist and this
person had a heart attack on the street
and I didn't deliver CPR I would be have
my license taken away I'm a lawyer the
only difference between my obligation
and the doctor's obligation is the
Constitution gives people the right to
assistance of counsel they don't have
this constitution says nothing about the
assistance of cardiologists I have a
very high duty to represent unpopular
people
well I think as I apply the same test to
the college donors
um the university should not have a
morals test
um whose money to take
um I I do draw a line about naming
rights of buildings
um and as I say that's an inconsistency
with my absolutism
but I just emotionally I just can't deal
with having you know as I said the
Jeffrey Epstein biological Laboratory
well for me emotionally there's nothing
that sickens me more in the University
than the abuse of power
right and there's a little awful lot of
people who abuse power university and
especially when it comes to abuse power
over students correct so sexual
harassment so in the realm of sexual
abuse of power and uh all kinds of other
well this is a crime to use one's power
position in order to take sexual
advantage of a student it's a crime yeah
um this is not a close question
yeah but it there's a legal crime
and there's uh deeply ethical crime and
there's an emotional response that I
have
you are
a good lawyer and perhaps a good man to
want to defend
some folks who are evil in this world I
don't think I have that emotional
fortitude well then you shouldn't be a
criminal defense lawyer or a
cardiologist
I think you're right
I'm still deeply sickened by Jeffrey
Epstein and uh The Faculty the
administration that still might be in
these Great American universities that
are abusing their power in small ways
and big ways but that's human nature you
get a little bit of power and you're in
a bad manner a bad woman and you take
advantage of it yep we see that in the
smallest of ways and in the biggest ways
and uh
institutions and regimes all across the
world
oh boy Harvey it's a complicated
situation well it's a complicated world
and it's complicated to be a human being
and this is nothing new